[موسيقى]
هي عباره عن حلم منذ الطفوله هو الحاجه دي
انغرزت في دماغي عن طريق الخيال والخيال
الخيال بيجي من افلام الكرتون الزول
بيشاهد افلام الكرتون وبالغمس فوقه بيحاول
يطلعها للواقع فبنحاول شوي شوي شوي شوي
على اساس اطلع الفكره للواقع كل الخيالات
المرات باي كل الحوس انا بحاول اطلعه
للواقع برنامج الروبوتات بعد ما شاهدتها
كثير من افلام الكرتون بتتحدث على
المخترعين وكانت الحته دي مميله عليه شديد
حكايه بتاعت 8 9 سنه في المرحله دي بدات
معي بالافكار انه اطلع اختراعات بحاول
اجمع خردويات على اساس شنو اطلع منه الشغل
اللي انا عايز اطلعه في المستقبل بعد
مرحله دلال الاساس الثانوي اجمع واجمع
واجمع وحدي ما حصلتها نهايه الثانوي بعتقد
شنو في الموضوع بشكل مباشر هسه انا بشتغل
وبوفر من القروش بتاعتي على اساس اشتري
ادوات ايوه انا بغيم هسا شغلي تحت الصفر
في المئه تحت الصفر في المئه من حيث
الانجاز لكن اذا عندي معدات انا ممكن احصل
الروبوت ده لعادي عشره في المئه استخدام
بشكل مباشر في محلات كثيره محلات المطاعم
مستشفيات نظافه حاجات كثيره ممكن يستعملوا
الروبوت اول حاجه انا مثلا محتاج لها عشان
اطور المشروع محتاج حاسوب محتاج يعني
الرعايه بتاعه في الدراسه كده يعني يكمل
تعليمه بغض النظر عن الخلفيه العلميه اللي
عنده لكن العين بصيره واليد قصيره
[موسيقى]